[Musique]
ce que vous voyez ici, c'est un
avion qui opère dans un
champ d'entraînement de la marine américaine qui a observé un
objet sphérique
dans cette zone
et pendant qu'ils le survolent, ils prennent une vidéo,
vous voyez ça ressemble, euh  réfléchissant dans cette
vidéo un peu réfléchissant
et il passe rapidement devant le cockpit
de l'avion et est-ce un
des phénomènes qu'on ne peut pas expliquer je
n'ai pas d'explication sur ce qu'est
cet objet spécifique
[Musique]
merci
je vous préviens, je dirais simplement qu'il
y a un certain nombre d'événements pour
lesquels nous n'avons pas d'explication. Avons-
nous connaissance d'un adversaire étranger
capable de déplacer des objets
euh sans aucun moyen de
propulsion perceptible ?  Je dirais que
nous ne connaissons aucun adversaire
capable de déplacer un objet sans
moyen de propulsion perceptible, mais cette fois, d'
autres ressources de la marine américaine observent également des
systèmes aériens sans pilote
et nous sommes maintenant raisonnablement sûrs que
ces triangles sont en corrélation avec les systèmes aériens sans pilote.
Musique]
tu penses
[Musique]